In fact, using electronic medical
records is part of the definition
of one of the most common forms
of patient centered care,
the patient centered medical home.
Elsewhere, a key culprit in creating
these coordination problems
has been paper records.
They can physically be in only one
place and are not easily shared.
Even if shared,
they may not be easily understood due
to legibility issues or differences
among physicians in the terms they
use to describe the same thing.
Most of Marla's specialists
use paper records.
Until recently here in the US
most physicians used them.
This is rapidly changing because
of the new federal policies
we'll explain in lesson two.
Electronic records and
data sharing can help coordinate care.
Here's data from a recent survey
of physicians who are using
these technologies, and
they substantially agree that it helps.
Improved communication,
more available data.
Interestingly and importantly, both
PCPs and specialists with electronic
records say care is more coordinated and
communications are improved.
Presumably because data is now
immediately available when and
where it is needed, as a majority
of these physicians reported.